jama a parlé d'une émission étrangère
dans le concept et de dîner avec une ex
ah oui voilà alors si vous deviez dîne
avec tout vos actes vous seriez prêt
jusqu'en juillet 2024 je pense à mon
avis tu sais me il a décidé d'appeler
dans son émission flavie flament way
voulu pour vous et dîner avec lui c'est
le laurier du gars qui fait monter la
sauce tout son émission pour un grand
moment de télévision
je vais appeler une ex à moi maintenant
direct la non et je lui ai proposé
d'aller dîner avec moi sérieux je vais
appeler mon ex donc dans un instant je
vais appeler ya près 25 teasing cet
appel à flavie flament vient enfin le
moment que la france attend tout ça pour
tomber sur son répondeur oui c'est le
budget est ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
faire un petit dîner prochainement voilà
pour échanger un peu sur le débat la
sueur sur la vie claire ma vie sauvage
et voilà rappelle moi c'était ça c'est
angoissant on voit la d13 ce pauvre
benjamin castaldi c'est thériault
[Applaudissements]
mais pas quand même se voir cette chose
quand même cela vous l'avez eue après
non religieux après vous avez alors vous
avez quoi en fait elle croit vraiment
que vous dînez avec elle non alors bah
non j'ai pas dîné avec elle non mais
elle vous a dit oui ça aurait pu être
possible
wissam eid tellement sympa oui non et
notre dîner soit elle vous avions à ces
horreurs qui a moins rigolé c'est votre
femme alors voilà votre femme ça
prendrait bien vous alliez dîner mais
que palin seulement eux non directement
du bord pas vraiment et on badine et non
loin d'elle on fait pas enfin si nous
admettons imaginons vous êtes avec votre
votre compagne d'alors et elle elle vous
dit je vais dîner avec mon ex meta
quêtes annexes
c'est dedans je faisais aussi ne suis
pas du tout les jours à venir
la jalousie je peux vous dire ça ne sert
à rien vous pour moi mais moi je vous
dis à moi de ma meuf elle peut tout
faire mais je vous le dis parce que non
mais payer si je suis sûr de moi oui par
trois mecs on perd mais c'est vrai mais
je suis sûr de moi oui oui oui oui voilà
oui mais non et je vous dis oui mais non
non moi franchement je vous le dis et je
vous donne un conseil ça ne sert à rien
d'étonnant si une moc doit vous trompez
sachez le il trouva toujours les moyens
de vous tromper même si vous êtes toute
la journée sur ses côtes
ça ne sert à rien est valable dans
l'autre sens dans l'option d'un mec vous
trompez il est capable de tout mais de
tout âge ajoute morgan et cassady la
chaîne portable
non anonymes non mais après tout je suis
d'accord avec toi donc je vous redonne
ce conseil je vous le dis ça ne sert à
rien d'être jaloux je vous jure que
c'est vrai avec tom vincent il va pas
dîné avec une ex voilà alors moi
franchement c103 du tout j'ai confiance
et si vous savez quoi
quand on a confiance en soi on a
confiance en l'autre moi j'ai pas envie
à l'oublier mais moi ce que j'en retiens
surtout de la séquence et que vous du
lundi au jeudi vous appelez macro et
décroche le label son ex elle décroche
même pas du tout ses sommets de faire
les yeux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
balderas gâteries alors tout le monde
m'a parlé de vos yeux aujourd'hui c'est
un truc de fou on essayait d'ouvrir
essayer d ouvrir au maximum
il est au maximum à lorient vidéo max et
frère mais sur une couleur des yeux sur
l'avers il a des yeux verts vont savais
même pas
[Rires]